i think these two pages or page and a
half were some of like the the best
stuff i've read all year where what you
do is you place two statements uh in
uh
contrast to each other both of which are
being promulgated by people who are
concerned about uh the power
differential um but the they're
intellectually in opposition to each
other the catechism of contradictions
that's right yes it's uh so for example
um show interest in multiculturalism
very reasonable
um do not culturally appropriate when it
is not your culture it is not for you
and you may not try it or do it you stay
away and so it's like okay i'm supposed
to show an interest and yet if i somehow
go too far then i i will be guilty of
something right mimick it right um
silence about racism is violence it's
like okay i need to say something and
then elevate the voices of the oppressed
over your own which is like look i can't
say anything unless i am of the
oppressed class and some people say it's
a happy medium just don't say too much
but the thing is it's so easy to be
called saying too much where is that
medium nobody is ever allowed to strike
it exactly
you must strive eternally to understand
the experiences of black people you can
never understand what it is to be black
and if you think you do you're a racist
you're racist if you think you get it
right yes uh you you know so they you
can see why people are kind of like uh
tiptoeing uh hot potatoing um through
this so that these
the these statements it is uh to me
maybe the most powerful one black people
cannot be held accountable for
everything every black person does i
would agree
um all whites must acknowledge their
personal complicitness in the per
perfect of whiteness throughout history
and it's different because of power and
so if you if you have power then you're
all complicit if you don't have power
everything is individual yeah who said
it doesn't make any sense
again and maybe it's because i've been
around the country but like that iowa
farmer and the diner would be like
you're complicit
like i've been sitting here in the
cornfields for eight generations like
you know what the hell did i do
[Music]
this week on forward we welcome columbia
linguistics professor john mcwhorter to
talk about his new book woke racism
which i really enjoyed the heck out of
met him on bill maher and he's on
forward this week
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to the forward podcast
columbia linguistics professor and
author of this incredible book woke
racism how a new religion has betrayed
black america john mcwhorter welcome
john thank you andrew i think i remember
that book
well now i mean you're talking about it
probably uh all the time though that
might be coming to an end your press
tour may finally this is the very end of
it this is the last interview yes 5 000
that's right
uh so you and i met uh in l.a on bill
maher's show we did uh and so i think
this should be the beginning of a new
tradition where anyone who's on a panel
together
has to then talk for real
as they come together
but i bought your book immediately after
you and i shared that stage i'm
flattered read it
loved it think it's so important
uh and i wanted to ask first and
foremost how has the experience been
doing press for the book promoting it
all of that jazz because i'd imagine
some of the reactions would be
varied shall we say
you know i think
i was expecting with woke racism to have
to deal with an awful lot of blowback
because what i'm saying are things
people don't want to hear and this time
it's not one of these john mcwhorter
makes black people angry books this one
is really written mostly for white
people and i thought now it's going to
be a whole lot of white people hating me
to tell you the truth
i'm pleased to say
that the book has done what i actually
hoped it would which is to speak to
center and left of center america people
who are concerned about race people who
want to do the right thing
but are falling for an idea that
striking poses is doing the right thing
and that that's how you replicate what
happened in the past and i think people
get it i think people actually see that
that's what the book means the book's
point is not everybody just stopped
talking about race i think a lot of
people are kind of waiting for the book
to be about that so they can jump on you
about it but it's not that so to tell
you the truth of the 400 000
[Laughter]
i've only had two or three where i had
really obnoxious pushback where i had to
really work hard and i think that's just
because the book isn't saying anything
all that unusual i'm just saying folks
let's really help people instead of
talking about it and striking poses and
saying things we don't believe because
those things don't help people
you talk about striking poses i think
the other thing you reference in the
book is living in fear it's like living
in fear does not help black people
so much of what we're told to say is
just people afraid of being called white
supremacists on twitter nobody wants to
be called that on twitter it's hard to
be hated for most people most people
aren't up for that and so i think that
what we're seeing now is the idea that
say somebody says all disparities
between black people and other people
are due to racism somebody says when i
see disparities of that kind i see
racism and let's say that that person
has a kind of a solemn demeanor let's
say that that person wears dreadlocks
and a suit at the same time and so that
looks kind of kind of deep and you think
i'm supposed to believe that i know deep
down that no
social history is as simple as that all
disparities are not due to
discrimination or even something
abstract like systemic racism that's
clearly not the case but you're supposed
to believe it you're afraid of being
called a name if you say you don't
believe it and so you pretend to but
that means we're having a very fake
conversation and a fake conversation is
not what black uplift is supposed to be
about
fake conversation is not what black
uplift is supposed to be about uh you
should have named the book that john i
think you missed
and then make that an acronym or
something yeah well so there were a
couple of things i picked up from the
book one is you're a literal linguistics
professor so i i love how precise you
are in language
i feel like you should have a naming
consultancy do you have that the
companies come to you and say hey we've
got this product does that happen no
andrew i worked for a company like that
once about 30 years ago for about 10
minutes i wasn't that good at it like
they no here's this product come up with
a name it's like call it
i don't know but as a linguist part of
you is
that you try to say exactly what you
mean and that is what this book was oh
to tell you the truth a lot of this book
is me in the summer of 2020
on a screened-in sun porch late at night
after my kids went to bed with a glass
of wine or sometimes something stronger
and just typing my heart out just
thinking i'm really angry at these
things going on and somebody needs to
say something and maybe they need to be
black and middle-aged and that's what i
did but yeah i tried to make it very
clear what i meant because it's so easy
to be misinterpreted on anything
and especially when you're talking about
these sensitive race issues
when you talk about the feedback you get
post interview how do you measure it so
one one thing is you go on to a tv
studio and then you have a particular
interaction with journalists and like
some of them are benign and some of them
you could tell they're trying to stick
it to you
[Laughter]
now what's funny is some of the
interviews i saw you do they did exactly
what um you said they someone would do
in the book is when you say hey this is
a problem and be like isn't this the
worst problem and you're like well i'm
not saying that that is not a problem
but i'm saying that this is
itself something that we should be
concerned about yeah the biggest
pushback against to this book
one of them is that i don't know enough
about religion to be pronouncing upon
this as a religion and that's true i
don't know that much about it and if i
were a religious person i would be
insulted by this book because i can tell
that people smell that i'm very
impatient with religious belief and
that's true that's the subject of
another book but it's created problems
in in my life so there is that
impatience but i get the feeling the
main pushback lately
is that the things going on on the right
are a more serious problem and that me
writing about this takeover of wokeness
is just some trivial business that will
pass and that i'm exaggerating and i
respectfully disagree for one thing it's
not just academia i'm not just writing
about some things happening to some
professors it's really gotten much
bigger than that and i just think that
if you really believe
that a culture of mendacity and
prosecution
taking over
how we are supposed to think how we're
supposed to research how we're supposed
to do art and how we're supposed to
moralize if anybody really thinks that
that's all just some trivia because of
what happened on january 6th and because
there are republicans who are trying to
disenfranchise black people and actually
not doing it very well on the ground
which i consider a relief
if you really don't think that what i'm
writing about is important either you
are one of the people i write about in
the book
or you've been trained to think that
because you're afraid of being called a
white supremacist on twitter i think
these things are very important i think
in some countries nobody would ask
whether it was important that academia
and the arts were being taken over and
it's also it is also media and it is
seeped into politics
and on a personal level i remember the
first time i was called a white
supremacist and i was like
what
that was like very very confusing to me
maybe because like i i just thought it
was so ridiculous like you know it's
possible that that it didn't
hurt me or frighten me in the way it it
would many others
um but now things like that have
happened to me frankly often enough
where you you do become kind of over it
where you're like oh
it's just yeah yeah and that's and it um
so i'm going to make a couple of
observations about the importance of
what you're talking about in terms of
our politics
so you write in the book that uh that
this belief system is primarily
concerned with what you call the power
differential and it's like the power
differential between whites and blacks
primarily though they're they're
different concepts
in general especially white men yet yes
so
uh i spent a lot of time campaigning in
iowa and new hampshire which were the
first two uh caucus and you know the
early voting states caucus and primary
respectively
uh and they're predominantly white iowa
is say 94 white new hampshire is 92
white
and so if you go to people in those
environments and say hey the biggest
problem facing us is you is the power
differential between
uh whites and non-whites and uh you if
you are white you need to really reflect
upon uh your racism uh and your behavior
um it's it's really
counterproductive is i guess a
you know euphemism for for what it is in
part because let's say you're a farmer
in iowa your life might not be
you know sunshine and roses like it
might actually be quite difficult
there might be yeah it might be very
very difficult and so when you get
presented with something that kind of
presumes that you're at the top of a
hierarchy
and uh and that you're sitting pretty
and that the suffering of others is what
you should be most concerned about
you're a little bit like well you know
my life is is very difficult um and it
would might even be difficult for me to
be overtly racist as a behavior because
there might not be anyone non-white
around for me
racist
right uh sitting in a diner everybody's
white you're eating your eggs right yes
yeah
and if you look at some of the
traditional battleground states that
democrats have been losing ground in
they are ohio missouri
wisconsin pennsylvania states that
aren't as predominantly white as iowa
but there are still majority white
and so if this is one of the things
you're leading with uh as a political
party um then it actually can really
push voters the other direction one of
my favorite insights that you get from
genuinely really smart people these days
on the left
is that what you just said doesn't
matter you know the new hot idea is that
that messaging does not affect the vote
it has nothing to do with how that kind
of possible swing voter feels about
democrats and so you condescend to them
you tell that white guy sitting there in
the diner he's not sure how his farm is
going to do even the people back in the
kitchen are white and you tell him that
he has white privilege because of his
white skin because of the history of the
country and he doesn't get it and he
sees that you look down on him for not
getting it to say that that somehow
doesn't matter i think that comes from
people who were just so wedded to the
supposed wisdom of that message that
they can't stand to hear it criticized
even when we're talking about whether
the democrats are going to have real
power in the future of this country i
think a lot of people genuinely think if
we have to give up talking in that way
if we have to give up preaching that
message then we are not ourselves i
think they'd rather lose elections than
consider how to break bread with real
people in the real world it's dangerous
it really does worry me because i'm not
a republican and i don't think i'm going
to be any time soon especially lately
but this messaging really doesn't work
the reason that people will fight for it
this hard and the point of the book
is to a large extent it's because these
people think of this as beyond question
this isn't just a political opinion this
idea about the power differentials this
is a religious
message that grounds a certain kind of
person's very sense of why they're on
this earth they must preach that good
news but that's not the attitude you
take when you want to win elections with
real people beyond college towns
[Music]
these days a lot of stuff's getting
delivered to our homes and why would
coffee be any different given that a lot
of us feel very strongly about it
trade will bring the best coffee in the
world right to your front door it will
match you to coffees that you'll love
from a selection over of over 400 plus
craft coffees we'll send you a freshly
roasted bag as often as you'd like trade
guarantees you'll love your first match
and on the off chance you don't they
will replace it with a different bag for
free you can give feedback
they'll tailor it to your tastes you can
feel good because it's sourced from
small us-based roasters who are
committed to ethical and sustainable
sourcing and for our listeners right now
trade is offering your first bag free
and five dollars off your bundle at
checkout to get yours go to
drinktrade.com
yang and use promo code yang take the
quiz to start your journey to the
perfect cup of coffee today that's
drinktrade.com yang promo code yang for
your first bag free and five dollars off
your bundle this holiday season you can
give the coffee lover in your life the
gift of better coffee too with their own
personalized gift coffee subscription
from trade enjoy and happy holidays
[Music]
yeah so we're gonna go into the
substance uh of uh how you characterize
this this belief system which i found
fascinating i'm just going to draw one
more example about
this infiltrating politics uh this kind
of terminology for a different group so
a poll recently came out that said that
approximately two percent
of uh latinos or hispanics uh refer to
themselves as latinx
and that something like 30 percent of
people found latinx off-putting it would
make them less likely to vote for
the candidate or group that is employing
this term
uh so to me the obvious thing is like
well maybe you don't want to use this
term because 98 of people don't think of
themselves this way and a third or so
are going to like you less if you use it
so where did this term come from and it
came from academic circles who were
i believe trying to address with what
they saw as
um like a gender issue yeah gender issue
in the term latino right um uh so if
your goal is to win elections uh have
control of
congress you can maybe make positive
things happen then you would look at
this and say well like this seems like a
terrible
idea or like a term that is is very very
counterproductive and so to your point
it's like well then what is the argument
for it and it's some kind of
ideological correctness that treats
voter responses as secondary or
irrelevant
if you say
latinx
a certain sliver of the population
applauds you
and that may strike you as the main goal
even if it's only a sliver and even if a
significant proportion of the people who
aren't applauding even find it
off-putting that's a weird situation
unless you see this rather liturgical
aspect to it i mean as far as i can see
latinx is going to become a term used by
people within highly educated circles
it's not going to spread beyond and you
could think of it as harmless it's going
to be the way a certain kind of person
usually with a phd or something close to
it says something that you say in those
circles most people are never going to
say it i live in jacksonville well the
issue is that what happens is you have
political figures who are surrounded by
professional staffers who will say use
this term
because they are of that mind yes and
they figure we need to please a certain
kind of person but suppose it isn't the
majority it's not about the world that
we live in in the neighborhood that i
live in i don't know the statistics but
frankly it feels to me as if every
second person is latino you hear as much
spanish as english on the street if not
more i have never heard the term latinx
used by any of those people and i'm sure
these are the people who often reject it
that has nothing to do with their world
view are we interested in their vote i
would think we'd be more interested in
their vote than in the vote of people
who went to college and listened to npr
and read the nation but instead there's
almost a kind of elitism but it's not
illegitimate it's that these people feel
this as a religious duty they wouldn't
put it that way but it's a religious
duty and sometimes you might let
religion supplant
what actually makes sense from a to b to
c if you feel you're serving some larger
purpose and i i am very pragmatic so i'm
all about like okay what's going to work
uh i named universal basic income the
freedom dividend because i tested better
with conservatives
out of you have the word freedom in
there they like it more
uh so
let's do a bit of level setting as we
get into the the substance of what you
say in your book
um
why you characterize this as uh
religious so a few things i think that
we agree on uh just to put them out
there so racism is real it's a real
thing it's there
uh
america is vastly unequal uh in terms of
particularly uh by race no even playing
field and is partly conditioned by race
that's right and
it would be a good thing to try and have
policies that reduce that inequality uh
and help black people it is part of
bringing us closer to our ideals yes yes
so uh i'm on board with those three
things i know you are too most people
right so right so so after you establish
those three three things then it's like
okay how do we actually try and make
something positive happen and this is
where you diverge very
significantly and i believe correctly
from this orthodox you described so um
you call this group of people and their
belief system the elect which i found
very interesting um i think the way that
people describe it out in uh the world
would be something about like wokeness
or uh political correctness what most
people think of as woke now yeah exactly
yeah
um
so how did the the elect get started uh
it started in a legal scholarship right
a lot of this traces partly
to
foucault
and a way of looking at literature where
there's no such thing as truth and
everything is about the position of the
person who wrote it these are things
that went on academia a lot of that gets
crystallized in what critical race
theory began us which is a few legal
scholars mostly of color who argue that
we need to reconceive our sense of how
justice works because
of the evil of racism because of power
differentials because of the experience
of someone who's below as opposed to
someone who's above and these people had
some extremist views about how say
vigilante justice should work about how
a person who's not white and especially
a man should think of themselves and
your primary sense of self should be
a sense that you are a victim of the
operations of other people all of this
stuff is it's strong brew it's not crazy
i don't think it's something that would
ever be embraced by most people but it
was just there
that has trickled down so this was
kimberly crenshaw richard delgado regina
austin derrick bell all of this got
really popular especially in the mid 80s
and if you you know hung around the
campus scene they were in my law school
textbooks by the way they were in there
and these people would visit campus i
remember once listening to
derek bell at a black graduation
ceremony this would be circa 1994 openly
saying genially but openly saying you
know you you guys are going to get your
butts kicked out there you've got to
really watch it the world is set against
you and that was considered a positive
message at the ceremony people ate it up
but that was a fringe thing most people
didn't think the way derek bell did and
he had some books that got around but
they partly got around because his ideas
were so strong and seemed almost
eccentric they were interesting it was
there was almost a drive-by aspect to
his ideas and you kind of i hate to put
it this way but you thought of him as
kind of an eccentric he had good ideas
he made you think but most people didn't
think like derek bell
it trickles through the 90s and the arts
into a more general idea that you're
supposed to place battling power
differentials at the center of any kind
of endeavor that takes mental candle
power it's the arts it's intellectual
it's legal and it's one thing to want to
battle differentials in power power
corrupts certainly it does but for that
to be the thing where if you step aside
from battling power differentials you
were ruled to be some kind of moral
pervert that's something that
crystallizes in academia slowly it had
become a problem even in the teens and
then our racial reckoning really focused
it because people who thought that way
acquired a kind of an authority
over the populist that they hadn't had
before so power differentials let's say
that's one of 10 things that you're
interested in that's the way it was
circa 2010. these people are saying that
power differentials are supposed to be
everything and what makes it really hard
is that they don't think of it that way
they're not thinking don't think about
10 things think only about power
differentials all they know is that they
think of the power differentials as
central they can't imagine why anybody
wouldn't who's a moral person so you say
why only this and for them you're asking
them to question truth itself so it's a
very delicate discussion but i really do
think we need to realize what these
people are so frustrating because of is
that they think of the power
differentials as what we must hold front
and center all the time most of us don't
feel that way so this
fixation on uh this particular
power relationship
starts out in elite law schools and
elite universities and i will say i
think that it's stronger in elite
universities and environments like if
you go to a random uh state school
someplace like i'm i'm not sure if it's
uh as prevalent particularly if you were
in like let's say part of the midwest
and maybe that's partially because of uh
i hear it's changing but i know what
general phenomenon you mean yeah
so uh and then that ends up um
very very influential in the media i
think in large part because a lot of
people who were trained in certain
environments then uh head to media
organizations a lot of them are based
here in new york um or l.a or l.a so so
you you have
this
very very significant part of the
culture gets into
uh really just about all of our forms of
media i'd say at this point um tv
permeated definitely uh journalism for
sure
it gets compounded by social media which
is used to kind of enforce a certain
conformity
social media really focuses this because
twitter and facebook become default in
09 and of course that doesn't mean the
world changed overnight but by the early
teens we were in a new world that kind
of person is very active on twitter that
kind of person kind of defines twitter
in many places and next thing you know a
certain assertion starts happening yeah
i i think that there is a very very
powerful
feedback loop between twitter and the
media exactly because media takes their
cues from twitter this group as you're
describing
i i think if you take twitter out of the
equation then you know it's actually
difficult to enforce
[Laughter]
if there were no twitter this wouldn't
have happened that's right they couldn't
have had this disproportionate influence
derek bell saying some colorful things
at a commencement is one thing but a
derek bell who's 27 and is on twitter
all day that's different
[Music]
so you write in the book about why
different people find
this fixation on the power differential
uh appealing
as a belief system uh so i'd love for
you to unpack that a little bit how did
this
gain so much currency and power it
gained power partly because if you are
an elect
you feel that you have a mission
you feel that you're seeing further than
most people who wouldn't like that you
have a sense of community with people
who are as on fire about these things as
you
but you know to tell you the truth a lot
of it is and i think we all feel this
way about certain things you feel
smarter than the average bear you see
further battling power differentials
you're the one who sees how important
that is and so there you go and you're
helping to save black people we have
progress in this country in that people
are so ashamed of being racist that's a
good thing if you're an elect then
you've got that covered because you have
devoted your whole heart and soul to
battling racism and supposedly saving
black people if you're black and you
fall for this it's different and it's
hard to talk about especially for me
but
you can
fall for the victimhood mindset the
victimization mindset is something that
psychologists recognize as a human trait
it's not about black people it's human
there's a certain kind of person who
exaggerates their victimhood you can
only do it if your life is really pretty
much okay you exaggerate your victimhood
and you dismiss the victimhood of other
people and you derive your sense of
significance from you being a survivor
of this supposed victimization that's a
mindset we all know the tattletale we
all know the martyr black america has a
way of oding on that because it's such a
terrible history we've got in this
country treat it like animals for
hundreds of years and jim crow
slavery even talk about redlining and
then there are even things today
depending on how you feel about
microaggressions it can be hard to be
proud
of being black it's easy to fall for the
idea that being black is inferior what
do you do about that there are all sorts
of things one thing a black person might
do is to grab on to this idea that what
makes you special is that you are a
victim of this ongoing onslaught of
racism that you and your people deal
with every day i think all of us can
understand how that would be a tempting
way of processing the world if there's a
hole inside of you if there's a hole in
black america's soul and i think many
people if they didn't hear me saying it
would agree completely there is a hole
one way to fill it is to manufacture a
sense of victimhood and to build your
identity around your being a noble
survivor
anybody would do that given black
people's history but that's what it is
and so white people and black people in
this elect religion end up doing a kind
of a dance white people pretend to agree
with this characterization of what being
black is like black people give white
people a certain kind of power we
absolve white people of their sin to an
extent but none of this has anything to
do with black people having real
problems including racially conditioned
systemic racism type ones out in the
real world this little dance is like
this cotillion that people are having
while the rest of the world burns and
i'm hoping to make people realize that's
what's going on
yes i i agree that that there are real
fundamental problems and let's work on
those um as opposed to monitoring
someone's statement on social media as
if if you just got that right then all
would be well right that's like how that
connects with this right yeah exactly um
so i'm going to share some uh stories
from my childhood to give you a sense as
to my reaction and one reason why i
believe that um what you're saying is so
important so i grew up one of the only
asian kids in my school my school is
predominantly white
there were two black kids
um there were you know two asian kids
like that kind of school um and so it
was very tough to be
black it was tough to be asian
the culture was somewhat different it
was like the 80s and 90s and so you know
like you remember like there wasn't
exactly a surplus of
i remember this well yeah yeah
um and so i got taunted for being asian
all the time um and the the black kids
had it tough too jewish kid had it tough
um and so there is like this sense that
i have from my upbringing um that
you know like
uh that racism
is something
that
i think
is
present
in a lot of people
in some form
in terms of their like attitudes towards
different people um and that
because of that i i don't have any
thoughts that's like oh we're going to
be in a place where you don't notice
that i'm asian like i mean that that
would be ridiculous
yeah and so then the question really is
how do we try and uh make concrete
changes in the real world i'm like less
interested in policing people's thoughts
or even to some extent uh their
statements
um and i'm more concerned about trying
to move things around in the real world
that will make
um a difference uh make things positive
i will also comment that if you were a
non-white kid in that era of 80s and 90s
like blackness was the only cool way to
not be white
if you know what i mean which is one of
the reasons why you had all of these
these hip hoppings yes right yeah you
know and so i had baggy jeans uh you
know like the whole thing and there were
a lot of white kids in the suburbs who
bought the food
like the rest of it i mean you know that
was like the
um like uh especially in my case as an
asian boy i felt like my masculinity was
always in question there's that trope
yes and so then and and so uh you know
um black culture was a way it's like oh
this is what non-white masculinity is
right
so
let's i remember this yeah yeah it's um
and i'm 70s i'm i'm a little bit older
and
i
got some trouble for being black i grew
up in very similar environments there
were two asians that i remember in my my
private school there were some black
people but it was white people who
called the tune and i'm from i can't
believe how old i'm getting i'm 56 i'm
from even before hip-hop and so in the
70s there wasn't yet this idea that
people who weren't black could pretend
to be that hadn't quite happened yet and
so the white kids were just being white
if anything they liked hard rock which i
never understood and the black kids well
you dealt with stuff and what i don't
get about today is that i'm supposed to
say
you hurt me by saying something or by
not saying something a generation before
me black person wouldn't have been hurt
but i am now i feel like that is giving
into something i'm saying that i'm in
the down position i'm pretending a
certain vulnerability there is i would
never want to do that there is some of
that where it's like um you know when i
was a kid and someone uh called me like
[ __ ] or something be confused maybe hurt
the rest of it um you know
at a certain point you feel like the
natural reaction
instead of screaming injustice on social
media would be just [ __ ] you
like you can't hurt me
you know
um but no that's not the current idea
and so yeah if somebody even called me
the n-word whoever it was chances are
there'd be something kind of wrong with
them and my idea would be if you did
that i'm looking down upon you just who
are you and now i'm gonna go do whatever
i was doing but no i'm supposed to you
know jump onto a bed and cry into the
pillow i was told to go back to my
country like you know not that long ago
but the person who said it was clearly
mentally ill so like
[Laughter]
right yeah go back to where you came
from
how stupid is that yeah so you know but
like person was you know like you know
they needed help so
[Laughter]
so there is um
so the this movement has
uh has some currency
um and you say that look this is
actually counterproductive for black
people in the real world and you have a
few examples in your book that i thought
were very very powerful and important so
on one hand it's like hey let's try and
modern moderate people's or
you know monitor people's behaviors and
statements and then you were like look
it's actually hurting black kids
right now because here are the real
issues and one one you put out there was
uh trying to
improve the discipline and behavior of
middle school kids and if you go and say
hey look like i'm not going to enforce
standards because
uh like these black kids cannot be
expected to conform
behave or conform to these standards you
know like that's actually a profound
disservice to the kids themselves yeah
and that's one of these things
there's a meme out there which is that
black boys are suspended for violence
disproportionately
not because in a great many schools
black boys are more violent than the
others now just let that drop you're not
even supposed to say it nevertheless as
unpleasant as the fact is
it's true
it couldn't be because of that it must
be because of bias
now the way to look at it is to pull the
camera back why are the black boys so
often more violent and poverty has a lot
to do with violence fatherlessness has a
lot to do with violence and everybody
knows that there is a lot of
fatherlessness in many
underserved black communities and why is
that you can talk about the war on drugs
you can talk about all sorts of things
but it's there there's a reason why the
black boys might be more violent but
nevertheless they are and studies have
proven this again and again and again
any big city that you live in probably
journalists at the big newspaper if
there still is one have gone out trying
to find this bias and didn't find it
study after study and yet there's this
idea that there's this bias against
black boys and the three b's are seen as
somehow being some kind of truth like
alliteration is truth and the thing is
if teachers hold back and don't suspend
black boys for violence which has
happened what happens is that big
surprise the schools get more violent
the grade point average of the school
goes down and i think some people are
thinking well good because those white
and asian kids in the school they
deserve that violence because it's going
to get back at all the things that have
been done for what no no no because you
have to remember that fact that
everybody knows that a disproportionate
number of black kids go to all black
schools it's just hurting other black
kids my kids who are being hurt nobody
wants to talk about it and so there's a
kind of person and it's not that i think
this person knows all of this and
insists on soldiering ahead all of us go
through life looking through a little a
little hole but there's a certain kind
of person who stands up there in a suit
talking about the bias against black
boys and everybody claps and they're not
thinking about the fact that if those
boys aren't disciplined other black boys
and girls are being beaten up in these
schools along with often the teachers it
should matter
yes you had another
problem which you called yale or jail
and what you're suggesting is that look
uh it's not that if you don't go to
uh yale then all of a sudden there's
nothing waiting for you but uh you know
ruined
you know that there's like a multitude
of highway that's right
of these other
opportunities and that sometimes putting
uh students in environments that aren't
the best fit for them actually ends up
hurting their ambitions i think you
cited a study where um you have
fewer scientists because they if they go
into some of these courses
um
uh and
uh majors that they
end up
being pushed out of them whereas if they
were in another
environment then they might actually
finish and then become that scientist
yep you see it again and again and you
know there are some counter studies that
are being done that are nibbling at the
edges of some of the specific claims of
that work but the larger truth is
painfully obvious and not refuted which
is that if a kid is admitted to a school
where everything is going to happen
faster than they're prepared for they're
not going to do as well they're not
going to have a good time they're going
to leave disenchanted and that's just
there and no study can eat away at that
there have been some things said about
stem in particular stem is one of many
subjects that people can major in in
school about which nothing has been said
and what it means is that to insist that
you have a certain percentage of for
example black kids at elite schools and
that you're going to do it by lowering
standards for most of the black kids so
that you can have that number ends up
hurting the black kids and there are
studies that you aren't shown i don't
think anybody's going whoo-hoo-ha-ha and
hiding them but when black kids like
that for example in california when
racial preferences were banned 25 years
ago started going to perfectly solid but
not flagship university of california
schools they did better kids at uc san
diego who would have been admitted to
berkeley or ucla and kind of treaded
water
did excellently at ucsd you would think
that that would have been on the
headline of every newspaper in the
country nobody cared because what you
were supposed to talk about was the
racism of banning racial preferences and
that just won't do a lot of black kids
who are admitted to the selective
schools would have a much better time
and have much better grades this also
goes for law schools if they were
admitted to the second tier but
excellent schools and i think some
people are thinking why should they
settle for the second tier but there are
all these people teaching and working at
these second tier schools who think of
themselves as being part of excellent
institutions what's so horrible about
them why does everybody have to go to
the top 32 and so this is a conversation
we don't have because what we're
supposed to talk about is solely racism
racism racism we must make these kids
welcome but often they'd feel more
welcome at a school where they were
being taught at a pace that they could
keep up with
the conversation has to change
[Music]
so
[Music]
a lot of things do end up being how a
young person develops confidence like if
you go into an environment and then
you're told you're good at something
then you're like ooh let me do more of
this you know and then or if you show up
and then you wind up with like c's and
you're very hanging on you'll be like oh
like i shouldn't be doing this right
yeah uh you know i'll tell a stupid
story but you know like like i think uh
you know i majored in economics in part
because i took an economics course and i
got an a and i was like ooh i guess i'm
good at this
right yeah so yeah you know i think
people being in environments where
they're told like hey you're actually
good at this make you a better person
than going somewhere where you feel like
there's something wrong with you and no
the problem is that maybe for reasons
connected with what we call systemic
racism maybe that's the reason you
weren't prepared for harvard that's not
where you belong you'd be better off at
rice you'd be better off at the
university of california san diego and
you'll have a grand old time maybe your
kid can go to yale and does it really
matter that much in the end but we don't
talk about that well you certainly don't
sound very asian talking about this man
i mean john if you go to an asian parent
and be like hey
no you don't you don't need to worry
about harvard
you would like to say it did they go
they would be like
they'd be like this man cannot teach my
child
[Laughter]
it's an unfortunate thing that we have
this and then the the law school studies
are so clear if you go to a law school
where you're taught at the at the speed
that you're used to being taught you're
more likely to pass the bar you're more
likely to get out of law school but we
don't talk about that and so for example
what was it um i've been doing the tour
so long i've forgotten where we are in
time it was last spring at georgetown
when a white professor said when she
thought nobody heard it was at the tail
end of his uh and she said to another
professor that she's concerned that the
black kids tend to cluster in the bottom
quarter of the class she didn't sneer it
she said it's a problem what are we
gonna do about this and the other
professor basically like nodded and said
yeah of course she lost her job and the
other professor now doesn't work there
anymore but she was talking about
something that's real everybody said why
you racist but nobody said prove it is
it that the kids are clustering at the
bottom and if they are what's the reason
and it's not because if anything it's
like that that professor expressing
concern should have been she's supposed
to be on the side of the angels yeah and
you know the kids who are clustering the
bottom and i don't know anything about
georgetown law school but i know that
that phenomenon would not be there if a
lot of those kids were just at some
other law school and getting law degrees
and passing the bar but the conversation
was not allowed the idea was just she's
a racist she has to go that's fake that
is what i hate to use this great
graceless analogy i've used it with
glenn lowry but there isn't one better
that is people peeing in their pants
that that is just it's it smells like
that and it's not real everybody
watching that knew we're supposed to
talk about why the black kids are
clustering in the bottom and try to
solve the problem instead she was just
fired for being a bad person that was
fake
now another problem you cite with this
approach
is that it doesn't help black people
themselves because it's leading them to
try and define themselves by what white
people think of them um which should not
be the
the
their primary uh lens of the world
here's where i get jealous of asians i
must admit because you can correct me if
i'm wrong i don't feel like that's as
much of an issue among asian americans
that you define yourself based on what
whites think of you you think of
yourself to ponder this guy okay sorry
continue john
the idea that
my sense of worth
is based on whether a white person sees
me fully whether the white person
insults me whether the white person
understands my humanity as exquisitely
as black people do that's my identity
and because white people don't see me
fully then my identity is how i grapple
with that how i position myself
according to that because they are in
power and i'm a subordinate my identity
my identity is that an asian thing well
this is a tell me if you guys know
because it it it does make it seem like
you're like this approach actually
subjects you more to
a white authority they win at uh
perception yeah um okay i will i will
reflect on this for a moment as an asian
guy
i don't think that much about what
people are well white people are
thinking about me because i you know and
because and this is going to sound this
you know it might be uh funnier
self-effacing because i don't think they
do think about me i like
like the average amount i mean you know
like it's i've joked in another context
like i've always felt like as an asian
guy you have sort of an invisibility
cloak you can put on at any moment
and so for us the problem
is that we're
seen as
kind of less masculine unthreatening
like uh not as american like like that
that that sort of thing exotic um yes
but
um but i i don't think asians uh think
in those terms like we don't get upset
um on the regular about how we're
perceived my sense of it yeah uh now of
course black people feel that we're
thought of as violent or angry and so
maybe that's different from being
thought of as facing and you know quiet
that might condition part of this but
yeah yeah yeah so so in my
my case growing up um so i i would get
really mad i'd go to the gym i'd study
martial arts be all ticked off i'd be
one of those angry asian guys in the gym
that was my my reaction i don't know if
you've ever seen i us i know what you
mean
guy friend
what's he doing now
uh hopefully
that response yeah but it's just one of
those things where my daughters are six
and nine and i think to myself are they
going to reach a point where they start
defining themselves not as their
wonderful selves but according to how
the white girls in their school don't
see them and i don't want that okay i so
th this is is so important it's like no
one should be defining their happiness
by other people perceive them no it's a
terrible way to live
you know it'll never work everybody
isn't going to like you and yet to an
extent even with you know we violent
black people to an extent my thought
often is white people aren't thinking
about me at all and that may be partly
because i'm black but that's fine with
me because i like the people who do
think about me and i'm busy well well
that's normal they aren't thinking about
your doctors they think about themselves
i think so yeah one of the things so i
was a very shy introverted asian kid um
and then maybe in sixth grade or at some
point i had this epiphany which was that
like you know i was all busy being
self-conscious sixth grade yeah it's
like the other kids were busy thinking
about how other people saw them they you
know
you know like they were closed
yeah they were too busy trying to figure
out how they were being evaluated uh so
you know they said that they were
evaluating me it was like very much
secondary or tertiary um
was was this thing i i had who knows
maybe i was saying something that would
make me feel better but
at that point i think there was a point
during my adolescence where i explicitly
remember saying to myself that uh
i will never
live according to how other people
uh or i think how other people see me
and so then this belief system you're
talking about now i'm realizing that
it's one reason why i find it um so
troubling it's like
you know you can't live like that you
have to you have a hard enough job
trying to figure out what makes you tick
your own values
what you care about your relationships
being a good
you know son brother friend father
parent like all that stuff is really
really tough
and it would be impossible if you
learned on top of that it's like oh how
does this abstract group
uh you know evaluate me see me it's
maybe one reason why i i have felt
somewhat um
you know uh like
less touched by by some of like the
um you know the social media
flagellation i might have received in
like uh moments in time and part of it
too is that uh it doesn't feel real to
me in part because nine times out of ten
um it would only happen online like if
you're in person someone then they'd be
like oh notice that
[Laughter]
people who yell and scream like that on
twitter most of them if they were in a
room with you would never behave that
way there's something that happens to
people when they're sitting there and
unfortunately it's not just this person
called the troll i think a lot of people
are thinking that the trolls are these
people who look kind of like danny
devito and there's something wrong with
them it's not trolls often it's your
friends it's it's people who are like
your friends they're very ordinary
people who will sit there on twitter and
rip somebody's entrails out and then go
out and be perfectly normal people
that's the weirdest human impulse i
think i have seen in my entire life but
it's there but yeah it's unreal it's
something somebody does with their
fingers when they're alone that didn't
come out right but it's not how they
would
in a real social space yeah yeah
that's certainly been my experience when
i traveled the country seeing people too
i think of americans as mostly good um
because i've been in a whole range of
environments with thousands of different
people
yeah and they have been mostly kind and
open and generous most people are and
cordial um and it's only when you uh
turn on your smartphone or watch our
news media does everyone just seem so
vicious
[Laughter]
and fixated on
um uh
race and like something i mean race is a
very important thing but it's like you
know people aren't obsessed uh about it
like every moment of their days like
that is not real life and twitter is a
bad neighborhood it's hard to remember
that but yeah it's not real life and
it's a bad neighborhood
[Music]
so so you have a couple of scripts which
i really enjoy that you recommend for
trying to uh address the elect with the
giant proviso that um that there's no
convincing anyone you cannot change
of anything and so you have to try and
navigate it and weaken it um are you
optimistic and you'd be the foremost
authority on this are you optimistic
that the fever is breaking that uh that
there are enough people who are coming
together being like yeah this stuff is
isn't working it's not improving lives
it's scaring everyone it's like you know
like uh driving people out of their own
neighborhoods et cetera et cetera like
like did you think and i if the fever
does break
i genuinely think you'd be a big reason
why well you know i
i wouldn't mind but i can't imagine i
would be that important but i like that
expression fever breaking because it
would that's the perfect analogy and i
do think it has broken i six months ago
i wasn't sure seven or eight months ago
but yeah i think as the pandemic has
lessened at least temporarily and we've
all kind of come out of our dens
i think people are realizing yes
systemic racism exists yes the racial
reckoning has been good in some ways but
we're allowing people to call the tune
who are so far off to the side of what
most of our concerns are
that if we let these people win we're
going to be living in an unrecognizable
world and so i'm seeing more and more
people
stand up to this kind of person the idea
is not to chase them out of the room
unfortunately they want to chase us out
of the room but i just say
for them i want them to sit back down it
used to be that that kind of person was
maybe one person at the party one person
at the faculty meeting one person at
starbucks one person contributing these
extremist views and making you think
about the way the world maybe should be
we were arriving at things by consensus
the grand old days of the early 2000
teens then social media messes it up and
we have this elect kind of person with a
miter on their head basically saying
that if you don't do it our way we're
going to call you a white supremacist on
twitter which is basically saying you
have to do it our way we cannot let
those people run the world because
frankly they have a very narrow view of
what it is to be an engaged person they
have very
very hazy plans as to how they would
actually run the world and frankly i
pity anybody who has to grow up in a
world that is focused only on battling
white's hold on power differentials
that's just too narrow considering what
a wide wondrous thing human existence is
so yeah at the end of the book i give
some scripts and what it basically comes
down to is just telling them no and so
if some small group of people said these
scripts are really funny to me it's like
it's like i don't consider myself a
white supremacist and nothing you say
will convince me otherwise
don't hold and don't look away and that
person then is going to call you a white
supremacist on twitter let them you know
and just let it blow over and notice
that it doesn't have as much effect as
it used to yeah yeah you also say like
if you do this then i will call you out
on twitter
try to take over my school with this
then i'm going to get a bunch of parents
and we're going to call you a racist on
twitter that's right i i will not
retract this
innocent thing i said or wrote and you
can call me anything you want
it's funny funny hearing it read back to
me but i really mean those
these scripts are really uh really funny
i like this one too you're telling me
i'm a racist but i am more committed to
actually helping poor people of color
than you are
that is a very important thing to say
because the person's gonna say you're a
racist no i'm helping black people
you're striking poses and i insist on
that i think you know it deep down and
if you call me a racist on twitter i'm
gonna keep doing what i'm doing if we
say that enough to this sort of person i
think that slowly it will emerge among
them that they can't just stand up and
yell white supremacists and get what
they want and if they start knowing that
that's it that means they've sat back
down they can say what they want but
they can't get what they want by saying
that they're going to call you a racist
on twitter we're allowing them to do
that and we don't want the world that
they would have us stuck in if we just
allowed that well again it's living in
fear i mean who wants to live in fear uh
you know um
and and that i think is one of people's
biggest frustrations with this time is
that uh good people moral people
uh feel like they're going to lose their
careers if they say the wrong thing uh
on a zoom or the wrong which apparently
has happened i mean i guess you pointed
this out
although you know andrew actually i'm
thinking a lot of that stuff is becoming
a little 20 20. these people who
actually lose their jobs because they
said the wrong thing there's a pushback
happening and so they're people who
would not have their jobs now who got
hung by this sort of thing in say march
2021 who are still in their jobs partly
because of what i think is a backlash
against the extremity and that's what i
hope this book is going to be part of
encouraging people to realize that
that's not racism that that gives me
hope the person i thought of just now
when you uh related that was a young
black woman named alexi
um i think her last name is hammond um
she was hired by teen vogue and then she
lost her job because of a tweet she uh
put out there that i think was
anti-asian when she was 17 years old by
the way a minor
and
and then x years later she was going to
take on senatorial position
and
the offer was rescinded and she lost
that job um and i thought to myself it's
like wait a minute one she was a minor
two she's a a black woman three she like
uh you know it's like she was like hey
apollo like at what point do you just
show some humanity and be like look like
where's the forgiveness yeah like who
wouldn't say something idiotic when
they're seven years when they're 17
years old like she didn't know that like
x years later she'd end up um you know
like
being uh and most publishing people
would not be bothered by this it's just
a certain type of elect person who is
speaking for asians i imagine in getting
rid of her and making it that she
doesn't have her job most asians most i
i will say you know i would never claim
to speak for an entire broad community
but i can say most asians like you know
would not have heard about this
controversy it didn't hurt their
feelings they weren't like in their
rooms crying over what this person said
when they were 17 years old i mean
that's part of it too is that nine times
out of ten the statement um was just
some place and seen by nobody uh you
know what i mean it's like what harm was
done
um 17 people yeah
like like you know 10 years ago fact of
it is a stain upon this person's
character that's what i mean by the
religious part that that only makes
sense if you're thinking about salem
massachusetts yeah yeah yeah so uh i
think these two pages or page and a half
were some of like the the best stuff
i've read all year where what you do is
you place two statements
uh in
um
contrast to each other both of which are
being promulgated by people who are
concerned about uh the power
differential um but the the they're
intellectually in opposition to each
other so i'll give you an example and
you know these well you must have have
now said this over here but i thought
this like i i found this to be brilliant
and uh the catechism of contradictions
that's right yes it's uh so for example
um show interest in multiculturalism
very reasonable
um do not culturally appropriate when it
is not your culture it is not for you
and you may not try it or do it you stay
away and so it's like okay i'm supposed
to show an interest and yet if i somehow
go too far then i i will be guilty of
something right mimick it right um
silence about racism is violence it's
like okay i need to say something and
then elevate the voices of the oppressed
over your own which is like look i can't
say anything unless i am of the
oppressed class and some people say it's
a happy medium just don't say too much
but the thing is it's so easy to be
called saying too much where is that
medium nobody is ever allowed to strike
it exactly
you must strive eternally to understand
the experiences of black people you can
never understand what it is to be black
and if you think you do you're a racist
you're racist if you think you get it
right yes uh you you know so they you
can see why people are kind of like uh
tiptoeing uh hot potatoing um through
this so that these
the these statements
it is uh
to me
maybe the most powerful one black people
cannot be held accountable for
everything every black person does i
would agree um all whites must
acknowledge their personal complicitness
in the
perfity of whiteness throughout history
and it's different because of power and
so if you if you have power then you're
all complicit if you don't have power
everything is individual yeah who said
it doesn't make any sense
again and maybe it's because i've been
around the country but like that iowa
farmer and the diner would be like
you're complicit
like i've been sitting here in the
cornfields for eight generations like
you know what the hell did i do you know
and and i will relate too as my
experience means that my my my my
my
parents immigrated here in the 60s as
grad students and then you know like i i
was born in upstate new york um in the
70s um so we're relatively recent
arrivals to this country so
so we got here listen right and of
course people say well you're benefiting
from the power structures that were set
up that's too abstract to make sense to
more than about 10 000 people ever i
feel and they're too many black people
who need help for us to engage in that
mental here we go again mental
masturbation of this notion of
complicitness it makes a certain
abstract sense if our life was a hard
philosophical problem or some play
but it isn't and it's time to knock it
off yeah well well i would say for
myself as a child of immigrants in a
relatively recent round of this country
in terms of multiple generations i
remember talking to a friend and him
talking about his like you know great
parents are great great grandparents um
and i think i thought to myself i was
like jeez like you know imagine yeah
imagine i was like you know my
my my parents grew up on a farm in
taiwan and so like like when i think
about what their gran like what their
parents or grandparents was like i
imagine they were on that farm
it was
probably the same place um but because
of that background i
really appreciate being american a great
deal because my parents came here and
we're like hey land of opportunity like
get educated
try and have opportunities right yeah
it's like to go from the farm to um new
york suburbs and one generation and then
for for me to go from those suburbs to
to the city and you know doing the
things that that i'm doing you know that
there is some uh
um awesomeness or magic uh to to this
country does it have deep problems yes
uh is racism very real yes should we be
trying to
um
mitigate uh the effects of racism and
reduce inequality in my opinion yes
um like is the intergenerational legacy
of slavery uh you know like is it
destroying lives to this day yes you
know like so like you you can understand
like the the depth of the problems um
but still have affection and
uh loyalty
um uh to the country and say like we
need to try and solve the real problems
if there's inter generational poverty in
black neighborhoods we should be
investing a ton in in my mind like that
the way that i wanted to do it was just
start giving everyone my
money which by the way would end up
helping
uh people with less more and you know
like i might not be running around
talking it's like help this group more
than that group but if you just you know
did something relatively even
you get to do what you want to right
yeah so that that was uh always my
perspective on it and it's something
that when i i do talk to people whose
families have been this country longer
which is most people
you know like
you you do have like a different
historical context that i i do try and
appreciate
um but
maybe it's because
you know
where we're recent arrivals i'm always
like okay what do we do now what do we
do now um and this is where i line up
with you 100 which is like okay what you
want me to do is apparently like monitor
uh turns of phrase and behaviors and and
perform certain uh rituals uh that
demonstrate my
my my uh sensitivity and everything like
that to this and i'm like i'm not sure
how that helps like that that person i
just passed who you know is on the
street but so or i could try and do
something that i think is going to help
um the person on the street and i very
much obviously the latter would be more
important yeah yeah i think um there's a
certain kind of black person i would say
middle-class black person who will tell
you that they encounter racism every day
that their experience of life is a
racist one
i disagree and that person will say well
how do you know and i'm gonna sell
because i'm a middle-class person and
i've been one for a long time little
stuff happens now and then but the idea
that racism is part of the american
fabric to the extent that people like
this are implying
is a fiction it's a melodramatic fiction
especially if you think about why people
come here how much better here is than
anywhere else and i think one of the
things i want in closing i want to say
one of the things that
props up this fiction is the
relationship between black men and the
cops and so my feeling is that to the
extent that we have a major cop problem
in this country in general and that it
is perceived sometimes misperceived but
perceived as particularly a black
problem we've got to fix that because i
think that
one generation of black men nationwide
who did not grow up thinking of the cops
as the enemy would be a generation much
less likely to fall for this elect way
of seeing things and i'd really like to
see that happen that's why i say no war
on drugs because i think that that would
mean 90 less interactions between black
men and the cops for all sorts of
reasons vocational school so that black
men have steady and relatively lucrative
incomes keeps you away from the cops the
cops are less likely the cops aren't
going to meet your kids that'll do that
sort of thing means that the whole cop
narrative goes away and then i think
we're in a position to have a more
constructive and realistic conversation
about race and so yeah the idea of what
racism is to build something it's not
just uh everybody you know pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps
book it's not a book saying white people
stop trying to help us it's just saying
help us for real instead of striking
poses on stage channel those energies
towards these things that might actually
help some real black kids in philly or
you know wherever phil is that's right
which is my town yeah i know just
through that out uh amen uh i can't wait
for the sequel it'll
i was be
next book is going to be a be about
something fun but i hope that people
take a message from this book that i
intended if the fever does break uh in
my opinion uh you'd be one of the big
reasons why woke racism how a new
religion has betrayed black america i
thought this was a very important book
and a great achievement and also very
principled and courageous and i'm going
to even say patriotic so thank you john
thank you andrew appreciate the heck out
of you sir this is great thank you
[Music]
you